股友们大家好,欢迎回到我的股市人生频道
今天是美东时间10月15号,周六
本周延续了上周的下跌,从周一开始
下跌周四,低开又大逆转,大涨2.6%
周五又大跌2.37%
又一个过山车
至于周四这个大逆转
很多人解释原因
周四早上的CPI数据并不好
又创40年新高了
怎么周四还会暴涨呢
解释不清了
其实看图形
在这里连续两天出现MACD的抵背离
一般这种情况下它都会有反弹的
表明咱们这个指标
它就是好用是吧
周五这个长阴线很不好啊
乌云盖顶
英文呢就叫做
Dark Cloud Cover
这个阴线它已经达到了阳线的一半
阳线实体的一半处
表明接下来它还会下跌
下周还有可能下跌
看布林线
它也是在布林中轨这里
遇到了阻力
掉头向下了
这也是它要继续下跌的标志
标普呢
现在似乎在这个小下行通道里运行了
在这里碰到通道的上缘
它会再下来
到下缘它会再弹起来
何时是个底
大家都在猜测
在预测
上次我们就预测
它会运行到第55这里
大约11月2号左右会有反弹
这个是根据费波纳切时间周期序列
时间窗来预测的
另外我们也可以从其他方面
比如从债券市场
来间接判断趋势
首先我们不能从当前的经济状况及预期来预测股市
因为股市本身就是超前于经济发展的
股市是领先经济的
要预测股市
还要看其他方面
比如说看债券是否已经止跌
很多人制作股票的不了解债券
认为目前加息
那买债券不是更好更赚钱吗
这是很多人的认知
其实相反
在这段时间里是股债双撒
比如TLT
它是20年期以上
美国国债iShare
它是从12月初就开始下跌
它从12月初的最高点已经下跌了36%了
TLT它比标普下跌的都要多要看债券和利率的关系我们看这张表复利限值系数表比如说是十年期的债券
面值是一块钱一张
在利率是6%的情况下
在这里
它的限值是0.5584
就是说现在购买它需要0.55美元
在利率升到10%的情况下
在这里
它的限值是0.38美元
就是说购买它需要0.38美元
表明随着利率的上升
债券的价格下降了
相反如果利率降到3%
债券的限值
一块钱的限值是0.74
就是说债券的价格就会上升到0.74美元
表明随着利率的下降
债券的价格上升了
就是说债券的价格和利率是负相关的关系
利率越高
债券的价格就越降低
债券的收益率就会升高
就像图里叠加的这两个曲线
上方的是国债收益率
下方的是债券TLT
我们看到它们是相反走向的关系
就是说如果现在买债券就很合适了
如果以前买的债券持有到现在的就会很痛苦
就像你买股票被套住了一样
记得这张图吧
这两条曲线
绿色的线是标普500的收益率
Yield
蓝色的是十年期国债的收益率
现在绿色的线是收益率是5.24
蓝色的是4.02
就是说现在买股票仍然优于买债券
虽然股票降了很多了股市
但是债市下跌的更多
下面我们来看债市和股市的翘翘板关系
在利率不变或者温和上涨的情况下
股市和债市是翘翘板的关系
一个高一个低
此时影响债券价格的主要是供求关系
债券安全又不会像某些股票一样会退市清零
所以如果债券收益高
大家就会去买债券
如果股票收益高
大家就会去买股票
这就是他们的互补的关系
但是在大幅激进加息的情况下
就不一样了
就像今年的大幅加息
结果大家都看到了是股债双杀
比如说TLT我们给它叠加一下
给它叠加一个SPY吧
SPY
出现了这个紫色的曲线就是SPY
标普500指数ETF让它代表股市我们看到在这里债券和股市是负相关悄悄板的关系
当债券在上涨的时候TLT在上涨
SPY就在下跌
在这里SPY上涨的时候TLT在下跌
随着今年利息的大幅上涨
看到他们两个都在下跌了
股债双沙
他们两个和利率的改变关系很大
即使在08年的时候
他们两个也是负相关的关系
这是08年
这个TLT债券在上涨
股市在下跌
这里他们仍然是负相关的关系
那时候也没有激进的加息
最近一段时间
我们看在市和股市的变化
虽然他们都下跌了
但是TLT
它在这里是从12月2号开始下跌了
而标普SPY是在这里
今年初1月4号开始下跌
它们相差了一个月
在这里TLT
这个紫色箭头这里
它是从8月2号开始下跌
但是SPY是从8月17号开始下跌
也是差两周的时间
就是说再是它会更超前的表现出这种变化
这不难理解
债券下跌表明利率上涨预期
股市就会下跌
相反如果债券止跌回升
在这里最近比如说下月债券止跌回升了
那么表明利率的下跌或者不再上升
股市就会上升
所以有人说看股市是否止跌
要看棒的债券是否止跌
他们有个时间差
如果债券没有止跌回升
那么股市也很难止跌回升
那么我们以后就要多关注债券了
比如看TLT
以上的这个理论呢
是主流市场分析的看法
是否正确
需要我们用时间来验证
TLT何时能止跌呢
我们看到它已经出现了KDG的背离
KDG向上 股价向下
还有CCI的背离
同样也是背离
它这里又出现了D9
周五的时候出现D9
表明它的反弹已经在路上了
我们以后要多关注TLT这些债券的变化
观点
10月之后美国通胀回落速度将加快
11月是观察美联储是否转向的关键窗口
11月份很重要
以上我们讲的是债券和股市的关系下面我们看关于OBV指标编程的一些问题上一次我们公布了这个OBV指标
它是这样子的两条曲线
同时我还有这个OBV1这个指标
我觉得这个除了颜色比较鲜艳以外
它其实实用也是一样的
这个OBV就是在30天均线以上的
把它设置成绿色的
30天均线以下的把它设置成红色的
这个指标的公式在这里
指标管理就是这样
这个公式的第一行
它的意思是
如果收盘价大于前一天
这个成交量就标记为正
如果收盘价小于前一天
就是下跌了
它的成交量就标记为负值
第二行的意思是
把1的结果
成交量
从very beginning给它加走
也就是求OBB
第三行呢是给OBV求30天均线
第四行就是画线
我们要把它画成
OBV在30天均线以上的是一个颜色
比如说是这个颜色
在30天均线以下的是这个颜色
这个颜色可以自己来设定
在这个颜色选择器里
每一个颜色点它对应一个数码
在这里RGB红绿蓝这里
它对应三个数字是三维吧
你改变这个点位
下方的这个数字三个数字它就会改变
你选一个自己比较喜欢的颜色
把这三个数字给它记下来
再回到复图里边
把这三个数敲进去
比如说它是237、76和127
把它敲进去
这个颜色就选好了
再选下方的30天均线以下的
假如说是这三个数
123、227、136
也把它敲进去
这个颜色又选好了
我们下来就给它测试应用
再回到主页
这个OBV指标就设好了
这样子的OBV指标似乎是更直接更容易看一些吧
OBV指标主要用在个股或者庄股
观察主力动向方面
效果比较显著
上一期
讲OVV指标时
讲过它的用法
想学习的朋友去看看那一期
今天就到这里
感谢大家观看
关注和转发
有问题请留言
咱们下次再见